right indicator how well our country is
doing how well our economy is doing
those are real numbers Walmart announced
others announced we had some tremendous
numbers come out today which I'm sure
you saw so we're very happy about that
we're doing very well the economy is
incredible the consumer probably above
all else the consumer is doing
incredibly so go ahead any questions
well I think we're going to have a very
long period of wealth and success other
countries are doing very poorly as you
know China is doing very very poorly the
tariffs have really bitten into China
they haven't bitten into us at all
except for the reporters don't want to
make it look that way but they don't
understand what's happening the tariffs
we've taken in close to sixty billion
dollars in tariff money and the consumer
has not paid for now at some point they
may have to pay something but they
understand that and who really
understands that is our great farmer the
farmers of this country really
understand if they know we had to do
something about China and we're doing
something about China with that being
said I think we're having very good
discussions with China they very much
want to make a deal we'll see what
happens we had a deal and they decided
not to make it now I think they would
like to have had that opportunity again
because I think they really would I
think they really missed a great
opportunity I think they feel that they
missed a great opportunity but China
very much wants to make a deal we're
talking to them we'll see what happens
yeah
well I'm only involved from the
standpoint of they are very anti-jewish
and they're very anti-israel I think
it's disgraceful the things they've said
you have lists of and this isn't just a
one line mistake what they've said about
Israel and Jewish people is a horrible
thing and they become the face of the
Democrat Party so I did absolutely put
out a very strong statement I think if
you look at their language if you look
at what they've said if I ever said it
it would be it would be a horrible it
would be a horrible month to put it
mildly so the things that they've said
Omar to lead what they've said is
disgraceful so I can't imagine why
Israel would let them in but if they
want to let them in they can but I can't
imagine why they would do I think the
longer the trade war goes on the weaker
China gets in the stronger we get would
take it in massive amounts of money
billions and billions of dollars Steve
as you know and I think the longer it
goes the stronger we get I have a
feeling it's going to go fairly short I
think it's going to be China's lost
millions of jobs you saw that reported
today thousands of companies are closing
in China and I don't know you know maybe
they want to do this for a year they'd
love to have somebody like Biden who
doesn't know what he's doing I mean I
just put a clip where he said oh we want
to build up China we want to build up
China well they gave us a very strong
China China's taking out over five
hundred billion dollars a year for many
years from our country and that's not
going to happen anymore well I am
concerned I wouldn't want to see a
violent crackdown I put a little bit of
a memo out last night he's been I like a
lot I get along with them very well
President Xi and I said that I would be
willing to bet that if he sat down with
the protesters a group of representative
protesters I'll bet he'd work it out in
15 minutes
better to work it out very quickly I
know it's not the kind of thing he does
but I think it wouldn't be a bad idea I
really believe if he sat down they have
a certain little leadership pool if he
sat down with that leadership pool I bet
he'd work something out very quickly it
really seems like things that could be
worked out pretty easily about who I
spoke to but I think my social media
statement pretty well speaks for itself
I feel that they are so anti-israel so
anti-jewish
again if other people made that
statement that would have been held to
pay so but I did speak to people over
there they said that they want to
retaliate that they're going to
retaliate because of the tariffs
increase that you announced what's your
response to that well if they did
retaliate which I don't think they will
do because we're talking to them and
they're offering things that are very
good I don't think they'll retaliate but
if they did we have the ultimate form of
retaliation I think that have very few
jobs left in China because we'd be able
to step it up just so you understand
I've been very mild about it very very
mild there's a long way I can go and
somebody had to take on what was
happening with China
we can't allow China to take out of our
country five hundred and seven billion
dollars every year not including
intellectual property theft and so many
other things so we're having very good
talks with China I think things will
happen but we'll see September the
meeting is still on as I understand it
but I think more importantly than
September we're talking by phone and
we're having very productive talks they
would like to do something I will tell
you that and the talk we had a few days
ago with my cue representatives nobody
knew what was on that talk except for
myself China and those two people that
was a very good conversation
we cut interest rates to more jpowel
should be cutting rates because every
country all over the world is cutting
and we want to stay sort of even and I
don't mind if we're higher we're better
were a better credit but we're way too
high
J Powell's made a big mistake he raised
them too fast and he also quantitative
tightened he didn't quantitative
tightening I was a big mistake fifty
billion dollars a month and it put us in
a position and interestingly even with
normalized interest rates
President Obama was paying nothing and
we have a much better economy and you
have to look at our economy also from
the day after my election because we
picked up tremendous team the day after
the election that's not attributable to
President Obama they only did that
because of us so when somebody says from
January 20th it's not from January 20th
that's from November 9th the day after
the election we picked up the fact that
I won lifted our economy greatly and if
I didn't win it would go down and
frankly if for some reason that happened
in the 2020 election you'll see this
economy go down the tubes I will tell
you that right now
you have any idea on when China's gonna
follow through on their egg purchases
and crack down on fentanyl they want to
follow through very quickly this was
part of the conversation that we had
they had a special representative
actually come over and talk to us a
different group and a message to me a
very strong message to me they want to
start doing that very quickly I'll be
honest I'm not there yet it's not China
I'm not there yet we'll see what happens
I do what I really would like to see
China in a humane way solve the problem
in Hong Kong you mainly solve the
problem in Hong Kong and I think they
could do it very quickly you know I said
yesterday I really have a lot of
confidence in President Xi I know that
if he sat down with their
representatives I have no doubt he would
solve that problem quickly
now I don't encourage or discourage I
think that if Israel allowed them to
come in for the normal reasons other
than those reasons I really believe that
it would be a terrible thing for Israel
I think it would show a terrible sign
they want to do boycotts they said
horrible things about Jewish people they
said horrible things about Israel and
Israelis I think would be a terrible
thing frankly for Israel to let these
two people who speak so badly about
Israel come in and they have become
amazingly the face of the Democrats the
Democrats don't want to do anything to
condemn them if they were if this were
ten years ago or if this were maybe a
different time or different people or
whatever they would be condemned for the
things they've said they've said some of
the worst things I've ever heard said
about Israel so how can Israel say Oh
welcome I I don't think would be a good
thing for Israel I don't know the
situation was Steve King it looked like
I read a statement that supposedly he
made I haven't been briefed on it but
certainly it wasn't a very good
statement
so we're dealing with the UK on trade
and a trade deal and we're going to have
a great deal made I've been dealing with
Boris Johnson I just spoke to him
yesterday I'll speak to him again he and
I are very much aligned we feel very
good about each other I think we'll make
a fantastic and big trade deal with the
UK actually we should do much more
business and we're doing with the UK you
know it's a there probably I I don't
want to say our closest because I don't
want to insult other people but
certainly or countries but certainly
they're one of our closest allies
anywhere in the world and we're going to
have a fantastic relationship with UK
and we're gonna have a great trade deal
with UK and that's moving along rapidly
I think just relationship we'll see what
happens we have a lot of things to
discuss a lot of things to discuss I
don't know corey lewandowski I think
would be terrific if he ran but I don't
know that he's going to run I spoke to
him about it a week ago frankly I think
it's something he'd like to do but I
don't know that he's going to do it I
think he'd be very good he's he loves
New Hampshire he loves our country if he
did it I think he'd be very formidable
we're going to look at that very closely
and we're looking at the whole gun
situation I do want people to remember
the words Mental Illness these people
are mentally ill and nobody talks about
that but these are mentally ill people
and people have to start thinking about
it I think we have to start building
institutions again because you know if
you look at the 60s and 70s so many of
these institutions were closed and the
people were just allowed to go onto the
streets and that was a terrible thing
for our country they closed them cities
couldn't afford them and they closed
them I mean I can tell you in New York
they closed a lot of them and the people
went out they went out onto the streets
and it's a terrible thing but a lot of
our conversation has to do with the fact
that we have to open up institutions we
can't let these people be on the streets
so we have a tremendous crowd in New
Hampshire it's all over the place
everybody saying wow our competitor has
virtually no crowd I don't know what
that means I assume that's a poll of
some kind but I think we're going to do
very well in New Hampshire New Hampshire
should have been one last time except we
had a lot of people come in at the last
moment which was a rather strange
situation thousands and thousands of
people coming in from locations unknown
but I knew where the location was but I
think we're going to have I think we're
going to have a tremendous success in
New Hampshire these are great people and
the relationship is very good
we're looking at it I feel very badly I
think he was very harshly sentenced but
we're looking at it very strongly people
feel very strongly about that I floated
it and I wanted to see where the
Democrats stood where the Republicans
stood people feel very strong about rod
Blagojevich in a sentence he's been in
there for seven and a half years it's a
long time and what he did was terrible
but it's a long time it's a long time
pushing makes Meccano on background
checks I've been dealing with Mitch
McConnell he's a man who we have had
tremendous success with judges and
judicial appointments we're going to be
up to a hundred and seventy-nine federal
judges within the next two months nobody
would have believed that's possible and
that was because President Obama was
unable to get him completed so I
inherited about a hundred and thirty
eight empty seats nobody can believe it
and we will have them almost all filled
with tremendous judges and tremendously
talented smart people they'll be filled
within two months so I have a hundred
and seventy nine judges and two Supreme
Court justices that's something that
nobody would have ever thought possible
I want to thank very much President
Obama for that background checks for gun
owners yeah we do I've been speaking to
Mitch about that I've been speaking
everybody about it and we don't want to
see crazy people owning guns but I also
want to remember that mental illness is
something nobody wants to talk about
these people are mentally ill and we
have to study that also because you know
it's them they pull the trigger the gun
doesn't pull the trigger they pull the
trigger so we have to look very
seriously at mental illness and we're
doing that at a level that hasn't been
done before
mr. president besides the Senate
Majority Leader and Pat Toomey is there
anyone else who many Republicans and
I'll tell you it's it's been pretty an
amazing experience they want to see
something happen and basically it's very
simple they don't want to have insane
people dangerous people really bad
people having guns Republicans agree
with me that I think you know I would
say pretty much uniformly afraid that if
we came up with a good bill I think the
Democrats then might up it and then do
things that can't be done and that the
public wouldn't want done I hope that
wouldn't happen but that's happened in
the past you understand I support strong
meaningful background checks where
people that should not have guns people
that are insane people that are mentally
ill people that are bad bad people like
this guy in Philadelphia who's been
arrested numerous times he's a bad guy
where people like that would not have
guns and frankly people like that should
be locked up he shouldn't have even been
on the streets thank you thank you very
much I will speak to him we have a call
scheduled soon president she will be
speaking to a very soon I really believe
he can work it out
I know him well if he wants to he can
work that out and a very humane fashion
he can work something that everybody's
happy thank you